welcome back to las vegas now from
liposuction to cellulite reduction and
so many other things my shape lipo the
sponsors of today's segment offer a
variety of treatments and here to tell
us more is the owner trevor schmidt
trevor thank you for being here thank
you so much for having me so we were
talking a little bit before we got
started you offer a lot of different
services tell us a little bit about what
people you know can take part in if they
come in and see you right so like the
name says is my shape we're removing fat
to essentially sculpt the body and
create the shapes that people want like
the hourglass figure
when we do our 360 light bulb which is
light liposuction all the way around the
waistline it it creates this uh we call
it booty pop is when you take the waist
to make the waist smaller it makes the
butt pop out naturally without adding
any additional fat so it's it's amazing
yeah that's that's a dream i'm sure for
people that come in and that's what
they're looking for and i know we have
some before and after pictures i want to
pull them up here because i just want to
show the effects so what are we looking
at here so this is a 360 lipo which you
can see how it forms that hourglass
figurine you see the side view how that
that booty pops out
but you know importantly you can also
see that that hanging belly at the
bottom
you know larger individuals the belly
starts to hang and we can completely
eliminate that and you can see there's
no scars from a tummy tuck so this is
liposuction only the skin always
retracts back
it's pretty amazing and is this
something permanent or do you have to
maintain it or what's that process like
so the removal of fat is permanent
however you still need to
live the lifestyle of us of a thinner
individual if you live the lifestyle of
a heavier individual it's inevitable
that you're going to recreate that
situation for yourself and if maybe some
people are experiencing pain and they
come in to see is this something that
can help with pain long-term yeah so you
know it's interesting in the removal of
fat you've got you get lots of different
changes to the body and it improves the
health by
decreasing the blood pressure if you
have diabetes it can decrease the the
need for medication
uh hormonal changes the liposuction is
amazing when you remove large volumes of
fat what it does to the body uh also
with the with the weight carrying on it
affects your joints your knees your hips
so removing that will absolutely make
the pain diminish and is liposuction
something that you recommend doing
before a full tummy tuck or what's that
process like so here that's the thing is
we eliminate the tummy tuck okay so when
you remove all that fat we can get the
belly to retract back and there's no
need for a tummy tuck so that's
eliminating the big scar
eliminating the tough recovery
eliminating the big expense of tummy
tuck this is a an alternative that's
that's incredible for the people that
really need it at this point yeah
eliminating the hard parts right
absolutely and if people are you know
new to this and they come and see you do
they come in for a consultation or how
is the how does that process work well
with the whole coven we've made it
really easy to where you can get your
your pricing on our quick quote which is
there's a link on our website
myshapelifo.com and you simply click
click the quote
enter some basic information and it
gives you a very accurate quote based
off of your your measurements well
trevor thank you so much for breaking
this all down for us and for sharing
some of those before and after pictures
it's always great to see the before and
after so thank you for being here and
thank you again to my shape lipo for
sponsoring this segment for more
information call
702-818-5476 or you can visit
myshapelipo.com
and don't forget about their special
offer 15 off all services las vegas now
we'll be right back